matt good to see you congratulations on
this man
thanks carlos good to see you man you
know we
i think the world was watching your
reaction and can to the big five minute
standing ovation and it must have been i
can't imagine the emotion that you were
feeling what was it about that
that moment that overtook you
uh yeah i don't you know i it was a lot
of things i think it and it kind of
just snuck up on me i didn't see it
coming um i
for the the the the overwhelming feeling
was that we were in we were all in a
movie theater again together
after so long and it just and i just was
reminded
how of how how how different that is
from any other way of watching something
and how great that
is and and and the feeling of being in
in the dark with a bunch of strangers in
that case that theater is so big there's
probably a thousand people there and
and um having the same you know
experience as a community of people who
love going to movies it's a really
you know i just i just and i didn't see
it coming i just
i just it kind of it kind of caught me
off guard
but but i was yeah it was really
emotional
yeah imagine thomas tom was saying the
same thing about that just just
being together and and celebrating
movies
together yeah exactly i mean and after
after 18 months of only watching things
another you know the other way which is
look i mean a lot of a lot of people
watch stuff at home now it's a much more
you know it's it's the
the the tvs are better the you know the
the the options of what to watch are
much better
i get it but um but it's a different
relationship you have when you control
it when you can stop and start it when
you
when you can be distracted by other
things that are going on
uh it's a different relationship you
have to the material than when you're
showing up at an appointed time with
other people and the movie starts at
that time whether you're in your seat or
not or
you know you have to be quiet because
other people are trying to watch and
it's just a kind of a different
there's a bit more of a reverence for
what you're watching it's a little more
like kind of going to church than it is
just
kind of having something on in the
background while you do other things in
your house
yeah you know i want to talk about bill
you know that i can count on both hands
and toes probably the amount of times
i've seen
a caricature of a character like bill in
a movie or a tv show
um but not very many times have we seen
someone
who everything is um in the portrayal of
this character everything is for a
purpose and everything is for a reason
um you know i know that you hung out
with uh with roughnecks get to know to
get to know them and
and understand where they're coming from
to play this guy but when you were
putting a story together was there
anything you were trying to avoid
doing purposely yeah well the most
important thing as an actor is you can
never
you can never step outside the
performance
and kind of comment on it you know like
like i
like the mistake in a portrayal like
this would be kind of looking down your
nose at this guy
right because he makes some decisions
that maybe you or i wouldn't make
that you have to really understand why
your character is doing what they do
and you're you're there you're their
advocate in a way
um you know and and i think in the rough
necks that we met
like they they were justifiably wary of
us at first like
like what are you guys doing like you
guys are gonna make a movie about a
rough neck like
kind of you know what are your
intentions kind of and uh
which is a fair question because this is
the kind of guy that the coastal elite
does
kind of stare down their nose at and and
they know that and
and uh but once they once they looked at
what we were doing and how we just were
trying to create a real accurate
portrayal of one of these guys and that
the movie really has empathy for this
guy
um you know they were unbelievably
helpful and gave us all kinds of access
i mean
took us out to oil rigs we you know met
all kinds of people
took us home met their families hung out
had barbecues at their houses like
we could not have done this without
without them um
and uh but but i think it was because
they saw
our our approach and our our attitude
towards the character was
was one of empathy and and compassion
right on it and totally shows man thank
you so much for this time
congratulations again on the film
thanks carlos appreciate it all the best
you